this is where most people stop and this
is why they don't win that's a quote
that has helped me get through some of
those like really tough times do I want
to win more than I want to fail yes this
is a Trevor quote my editor and my
closest friend he said well whenever
someone says they can't stand it anymore
well if you're alive you have proof that
you can stand it and if you die you
won't have to stand it anymore so you
can always stand it and I think that's a
really powerful message that's like the
gift that we all have we all have stood
life to this point and I think that's
like all the proof you need that you can
keep standing